- Here it comes.
I'm getting it ready for you (laughs).
(upbeat music)
That's my baby's food and I'm
going to give it to people
who are probably going to
say like oh this is gross.
- I'm kind of hoping that it tastes like
unsweetened vanilla Trader Joe's milk.
- I'm hoping that it
tastes like regular milk.
- Man, this is baby juice.
Like this is supposed to
keep little kids alive,
so I feel like it's going
to be full of nutrition.
- I've always wanted to try it.
I think it'll be like regular milk,
but sort of like the difference
between beer and root beer.
- Maybe it'll make us
feel like kids again.
- I don't know why I think
it's going to be really gross.
(sighs)
- Oh my God, it's thick.
- It's just too real.
(laughs)
- I can't smell a thing.
- It doesn't smell like anything.
Maybe chalk.
- It smells like milk.
Oh, does it smell sour to you?
- I don't know.
- It's nice eggshell green.
- For our mothers.
- (mumbles)
- Oh hi.
- Okay, you know what (laughs).
- It's like pretty good.
- Oh my God, it's actually really good.
- There's like a kind of aftertaste
that tastes like a baby smells though.
- Like after I'm finished drinking this,
the only thing I'm going to need
is for someone to pat my
back so that I can burp.
- [Voiceover] So we'd like
to introduce you to someone.
- Who?
That's your boob?
- Is that your milk?
- Yeah (laughs).
- [Voiceover] Hello.
- Hi.
- [Voiceover] It's my milk.
- Oh my gosh, we're so honored.
(laughs)
- [Voiceover] Surprise.
- Ochi (laughs).
Oh my God.
- We're your babies now.
- Oh, you're babies.
(laughs)
- This came out of a woman.
- This came out of a woman's tit.
- Yeah.